all right what's going on guys this is
rob and in this video we are covering
the hellfire gala but here's what we're
gonna do because marvel's never really
done an event like this i mean i guess
they kind of did maybe back during the
days like the first appearance of emma
frost but not really in this way
so the hellfire gala is as much a
crossover event or really like an
x-men crossover event as it is any other
event right
fall of mutants or decimation or
anything like that
but it's so interesting and so
intriguing the way that it's done so
we're going to cover how it starts and
we're going to cover how it ends
and then i want to hear from you guys
whether or not you want to see what
happens in between
it's not super important but i guess it
could kind of beef things up if you guys
are interested in it and so if we do
then we'll just kind of go through and
add them as tie-ins more or less but the
way this kicks off is kind of the
beginning of this
this sort of gala right people kind of
arriving in the relatively early day
things along those lines and the reality
is because this is the curcumin gala and
because the x-men are familiar with
everybody
this is a veritable who's who who shows
up to this place right i mean like
everybody's here if it was gonna be a
great big huge press event they'd ask
the red carpet and the who's who of the
superhero community has arrived you know
what it reminds me of it reminds me of
the wedding between black panther and
storm during civil war right that's what
it reminds me of but of course you
basically have like the avengers who
were showing up here so captain america
uh carol danvers thor blade uh ghost
rider robert reyes
she hulk you have the fantastic four who
show up here and one of the things is
kind of discussed again much like the
wedding of black panther and storm is
that any rivalries that may exist
between the mutant population and
anybody else are basically being removed
but the important thing is we basically
get like
all these people kind of putting their
their beef to the side and then in turn
kind of coming together and meeting at
this sort of huge event now the biggest
question is
why are they here the reality of this is
that one of the things that jonathan
hickman's been doing with the x-men over
the course of this run
and really all the other writers ed
brisson and and teeny howard and so on
when it comes to the x-men
or really mutants in the world as a
whole krakow is very hush-hush
right you can't get in there unless
you're a mutant and mutants aren't
spilling the beans on what's going on
in there so this is as much curiosity as
it is anything else
so when people received invitations for
the first ever gala
in the nation of gracoa of course they
were going to show up
one of the cool things you get jay jonah
jameson here which is pretty awesome and
it looks like you have oswald patton i
don't know if that's true or not but
nonetheless like you it's one of the
things they actually throw celebrities
in here and in fact they'll be a huge
celebrity that shows up in this video
but nonetheless there's still
a little bit of beef even if it's one of
these things where like a lot of that
kind of stuff gets put aside
at the end of the day you actually have
this instance where reed richards
approaches
uh professor x now the last time these
two guys met
if you guys recall it was the video that
we did of fantastic four versus the
x-men and it was essentially this idea
that charles xavier had believed that
franklin richards was a mutant and the
idea was that he belonged in krakowa and
so there was a lot of beef going
on between the x-men and the fantastic
four over whether or not franklin should
actually be allowed to go to kokoa now
the big thing about this is later on and
probably one of the most poor decisions
that marvel had made they kind of had
this sort of throwaway moment
it wasn't it was a little drawn out
right like a few pages but honestly it
was just kind of a last minute decision
that it was basically professor x
showing up to franklin and being like oh
yeah so here's the thing man
after further analysis we realize you're
not a mutant uh so you can't come to
krakowa right that's basically what it
was
it seemed kind of nonsensical but it's
cool to see franklin here right to see
franklin show up and basically spend
time and kind of join around with the
mutants in krakowa
itself now if i'm a betty man that's
probably going to go away and franklin
may very well be solidified as a mutant
in the end it doesn't really matter
mutant or not the guy's
as powerful as virtually any god out
there but you do kind of have
everything sort of going on now while
that's happening one of the funny things
is that emma frost kind of communicates
with everybody here
using your telepathy and just kind of
says like good evening you know welcome
everybody
one of the things that krakow is doing
here and one of the things that makes it
so unique in terms of a gala is that
people have powers right if this was
just any normal gal they'd just be a
bunch of rich and titled folks who were
hanging out and just kind of patting
themselves in the back and just talking
about how awesome they are right but the
reality is that here on krakow when you
come to a gala up here you get the whole
glitz and glamour so there's actually a
woman who comes up here that basically
starts playing
an instrument for them right which is
more or less like a coincello is really
what it seems to be
but rhapsody is one of these characters
where as she plays this music she emits
this kind these kind of butterflies
right kind of a physical manifestation
of her powers
and they actually bond to individual
people and it's not only them
listening to her play it's actually them
experiencing what it's like
to play as a master right to play as a
person who's able to play a string
instrument you know in in such a
prodigious way and so it's pretty
awesome now while that's going on doctor
doom's like bah
you know like get away from me butterfly
[Laughter]
i don't care about this stupidity but
for the most part it's pretty well
received i mean you do have a few people
who are there that are pretty sus
right you've got a ambassador brasso
who's basically a guy who's kind of like
you know looking for what he can to kind
of use his ammo against mutants if at
all possible and then of course ben
grimm basically starts gambling right
starts starts
throwing dice she's like it's gambling
time you know it's that's a that's a
little bit of a funny thing but again
it's kind of
all this interesting stuff going on now
one of the things that happens here
which is really cool
is that emma frost actually has a bit of
a conversation with captain america now
one of the big things to know is that
emma frost
basically got dumped by cyclops when
jean grey was officially back
right because as we know cyclops and
jean grey had been together for
forever right i mean they were like the
original x-men couple um eventually
emma frost kind of stepped in following
the perceived death of jean grey and
basically was knocking boots with
cyclops and then when jean grey came
back her relationship with cyclops was
on the rocks but they couldn't actually
do
like say it physically happened right it
was it was one of those weird things but
ever since then right like emma frost
has been on the market
and captain america man he's he's
stepping up right like captain america
is like okay
like you know let's let's let's see if
this is worth the price of admission and
so it's a it's kind of a funny thing but
but in all reality he's not really he's
not really digging it right i mean that
doesn't really seem to be the case but
there does seem to be a little beef
between him and
and victor von doom more or less they're
kind of having like they're just staring
each other down but all indications
is that it's going to kind of break down
into a bit of a conflict because this is
everybody basically putting their their
disagreements and issues to the side
then it's one of those
we don't we don't engage in conflict
here right we don't fight here now one
of the other things that kind of goes on
is you've actually got this interesting
little segment with a woman by the name
of wilhelmina now wilhelmina we had
talked about in a previous video
was basically one of the heirs to the
new hellfire club right she was kind of
there with cade kilgore
and so on there's some stuff that goes
on in the background the important thing
is they seem to have kind of wiped that
and then in turn the stepford kaku is
basically returning to her this is
really just kind of a plot thread all
this is designed to do is kind of set
things up for a future story
it's not overly important but it's a
story we'll likely cover so i'm covering
it here just so that in the future i can
kind of reference back to this point and
just say hey like remember when we
talked about wilhelmina and the hellfire
the new hellfire club and that kind of
thing and so the important thing that
goes on
is that following this it's just kind of
general conversation among people and
it's cool to see this kind of go down
right folks that just never really meet
or never really hang out or never really
talk to each other that you get to see
them do all those things right i mean
there's a lot of celebrities who are
drawn here and some of them
i feel like i should know who they are
and a lot of them i don't but you know
it's kind of one of these these sort of
light-hearted conversations that go on
but kind of following emma frost one of
the things that happens
is that as you have captain america
talking to henry peter guyrick that she
kind of starts hitting around and sort
of reading the mind of steve rogers and
she's having this conversation right
with and just kind of being like hey
so like you know i mean i know we're
kind of busy for relationships but i
mean you know
it's captain america right i mean you
know like
[Laughter]
who wouldn't want to get steve rogers
between the sheets you know what i'm
saying but then like as she's reading
his mind she's like oh my god
i remind him of his mother which i feel
like for every woman that's like super
attracted to a guy
that's the worst thing to have happen
right to be like you remind me of my mom
like i know
just from like seeing that go down
that's never a good thing
that will kill any possible romantic
chemistry you have
no woman wants to be reminded of a man's
mom right or at least like a motherly
figure right like she wants to be
you know seen as like sexy and
attractive you know that kind of a thing
so again
it's a little bit of a funny kind of
conversation going on but what we end up
doing here is actually
bouncing forward to the end of the night
now before we get there again
there were kind of a lot of things that
were that were going on some were
important some weren't
so again i'll kind of leave it to you
guys to let me know exactly what it is
that that you know you guys want me to
cover if you want to do all the ties and
stuff like that and so instead what
we're going to do is we're going to pick
up
basically when name with a submariner
first arrived here now this is probably
one of the coolest moments here because
name of the submariner is just kind of
hanging out on this boat right out there
outside of of corcoa in the somewhat
early evening and you've got charles
xavier and you got magneto who show up
here looking like pimps and then in turn
they kind of have this conversation with
with neymar the submariner ultimately
and it's one of the things that are
interesting
they they of course you know ingratiate
themselves and say hey you know we're so
honored to have you
because you're a king right we're
humbled and honored to have you here
and neymar is not biting right like i
mean that's one of the things name with
a submariner as a king
is one of those where he expects people
to
recognize the fact that he's a king but
he doesn't want people to lick his boots
you know what i mean
like like recognize my role in this
world but don't kiss my rear end right
you know and that's that's one of the
things that kind of goes on here you
think they know it by now
but he kind of asked them like how's the
empire building right because from
neymar's perspective that's basically
what they're doing is trying to build an
empire here and of course they basically
say well i mean you know we've got
people that we've defeated and people
are taking their place and when we
defeat them
others will take their place so we're
gonna have like a never-ending string of
of basically adversaries and enemies
that we have to face against but you
know
changes are coming to the quiet council
we can offer you a seat on the council
now name of the submariner's response to
this is amazing right he says you're
gonna offer me a seat
offer me a seat on the quiet council of
krakowa
wow i mean yeah i guess i am a mutant
wow offer me a seat
that's interesting because i think if i
stepped one foot
into your castle chamber there would be
a rush to surrender a sea to me even
if none were available frauds tend to
flee
at the sight of a true aristocrat i am a
real king
never forget this and so professor x
gets a little snarky here and says that
you should probably return home to your
people
and be a king to your people and that's
when neymar kind of comes out and says
you know i'm going to be honest every
day when i go to bed and i dream at
night i dream of conquering the world i
dream that humans
mutants anybody out there that occupies
the surface
bends at my whim right they do exactly
what i tell them to and that they're
that
they're all blind and they can finally
see and see me
as i really am that i am a king i am a
ruler of this world you guys are
pretenders
and that's one of the things that he
says he's like you know i assure you
being a king is not being on a council
with those who pretend to be my peers
and then he has this amazing line where
he says i have dominion
over 70 of this planet gentleman you
currently control
what an island get back to me when you
have something more to offer like this
it's the
the best retort ever because that's kind
of name with a submariner
it's one of these things where the whole
concept of kokoa kind of gets put
into into perspective right that it
really is just these guys who just
run an island rahu right like i mean for
all intents and purposes name of the
submariner rules the ocean they ruled a
landmass that amounts to something a bit
bigger than like alaska
right like okay cool whatever name of
the submariner could flood the whole
place and pretty much
ruin it if you wanted to we saw him do
that with wakanda so
again it's a little a little nuts but as
you get towards the end of the night
again kind of jumping forward here that
you basically pick up with a kind of
conclusion of events here and this is a
really really big moment and it's really
kind of a follow-up to the events of ten
of swords
because one of the things that we saw is
that in the aftermath of ten of swords
cyclops and jean grey had stepped away
from the quiet council they basically
left
as leaders of the mutant nation and
wanted to go back to their role of kind
of being
members of the x-men or really
superheroes who were doing superhero
things kind of being on the front lines
and and saving or protecting krakowa as
best they could but the other part of
this
is that a new x-men team needed to be
chosen and when the question was asked
are our cyclops and gene going to pick
the team how's this going to work the
response they had was we should have a
vote and so that's where this comes into
play that jean grey basically reaches
out telepathically and says
it's time for us to now pick who it is
that's going to be our new x-men
team right they have to be the ones that
are selected and unanimously
chosen by the mutant population of earth
and so she reaches out to
every single mutant across the entire
world and basically says
cast your vote now while that's going on
doctor strange is basically using his
power to
like spy right he's ease dropping you
know like like doctor strange doesn't
have any business of his own to mind so
he's mining everybody else's business
you know what i mean he's old he's like
an old person
right just mining everybody else's
business
even johnny storm is kind of like i mean
i don't really know we should be doing
that but like but like what are they
saying though
so it's one of those those kind of funny
little things but essentially everybody
votes and it happens pretty fast
so our new x-men team step forward right
rogue sun fire wolverine sync
and polaris this is a unique roster and
here's the funny thing about it there's
some heavy hitters here man like one of
the things to remember is that rogue's
powers have waxed and waned in recent
years
in the aftermath of messiah complex she
had the ability to copy more than one
power at the same time it's since gone
back to one
but like that option's been presented
now which means it may very well likely
return
you've got cyclops you've got jean grey
you know kind of doing their thing
you've got wolverine right so x23
is officially part of the the really the
main wolverine on the x-men roster now
sun fire is ridiculously overpowered
literally just just
living fire right i mean he's pretty
amazing sync and copy the powers of
all these people and lorna is basically
magneto right so i mean this is a heavy
hitting x-men team and i love the roster
right like i love the way this whole
team is played out but at the end of the
day
you end up having emma frost kind of
presenting herself to everybody and
saying okay
i cannot tell you how happy i am that
all of you here have accepted my
invitation that all of you here have
arrived but it's now
time for us to begin winding the night
down while that's going on you've
actually got cyclops who's basically
it looks like post malone is trying to
get a get a drink at the bar
and so cyclops helps him get a drink and
then when he turns around this guy's
like what's your story and it's kevin
feige right so kevin feige appears in
the x-men comics which is pretty cool i
wish i could appear in the x-men comics
that'd be awesome you know you know what
my role would be
there'd be there'd be some kind of fight
you would just see a guy who's just
standing there watching it all go down
it'd be like two panels and like i'd be
vaping and they'd be like that's
nuts and like that's it that's that's
all you would get that's all you would
see of me in the x-men comics
the cool thing about this is that
cyclops kind of tells a story to kevin
feige
over why he is the way he is and and how
he kind of got to where he was what his
identity is
he was basically blind to how the world
worked and then he met a man
who taught him how to see how things
really work and this is kind of
interesting because he says i love this
man for it right and as he began to
become more capable then he came to this
realization that the world can often be
a rough place the world can often be
hard right that the world can kill your
dreams but the important thing is to
always keep dreaming to always keep
going to set your sight on a goal
and that with enough time and effort
that goal can come to fruition and so
that's when he kind of follows up and
says you know what's my story i'm a
dreamer
right i'm an x-man i'm a man who follows
the dream of professor charles xavier
but again
one of the kind of undercurrents going
on here from everything that we've seen
especially with regards to mystique is
something's pretty sus here right like
this ain't all glitz and glamour right
it's not all sunshine and rainbows here
man like
something bad's really about to happen
but with the night basically winding
down and everything kind of coming to an
end that what you
have is this kind of gif by emma frost
we don't initially find out what it is
but she says she's going to connect
all of their minds right all of us human
and mutant as i want to offer you a
unique view of the show you can refuse
of course but fair warning this is one
of those
where were you at when this happened
moments
and so what this looks like is this kind
of the fireworks celebration that's
being done
in a kind of telepathic sense which is
actually a genius idea because being
able to use telepathy to manipulate the
means by which people see things
will allow them to see things in a way
that nobody could really see before and
that's when she kind of says right
fireworks right at this evening's
end which is not the end at all but the
beginning of a new age
and seemingly two individuals come to
sending down but we never really find
out who these guys are instead the comic
ends with that being said guys thanks
for watching
make sure you guys let me know in the
comments if you guys want me to finish
the kind of
of the tie-ins to this and i will catch
you all later
peace